[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guests this week is a
journalist and the author of the great
betrayal the true story of brexit Ron
little welcome to trigonometry thanks so
much for asking me thank you it's great
to have you before I go and this is the
book make sure you get it this is what
we were talking about but before before
we get into it for anyone who doesn't
know who you are which is a small number
of people these days just tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been your journey through life
because we always find that quite
interesting all right okay sure well I'm
a media [ __ ] and I'm a journalist a
hack a columnist for The Sunday Times
The Spectator in the Sun I once was a
speechwriter for the BBC after that I
worked at speechwriter for the BBC
there's a Freudian sin the arrogance we
tried it for the labour party after that
worked for the BBC and it found the
illusion between the two very easy
indeed as you can imagine my point has
always been to to say what I think
people believe but are too scared to say
for reasons of either direct political
correctness or indirect political
correctness is a slight difference
between the two and also to make people
laugh or even less my job is to is to is
to amuse for that I usually get called a
racist and a homophobe because I have
made jokes about black people before and
indeed gay people but I like to think of
myself in a very real sense as an Equal
Opportunities [ __ ] as someone who will
offend everybody including you know the
people I've come from up in the
northeast of England and people who live
in Brighton especially maybe people who
live in Brighton and French people and
everyone know that they are all in there
I don't think I think everybody has
to have the piss taken out of them
including me I think that's a beautiful
thing about the French and that people
say you can't take the piss out black
people gay people but French accept your
changes you know used to be like that
about the Welsh I tried that a couple of
years ago stop that Boyle you know it
wasn't leave it was one of the least
offensive things I've ever said in my
life I happened to mention that there
was a paucity of vowels in the Welsh
language which isn't a terribly original
observation nor a terribly funny one and
they went to Lally and the Welsh
language society said it's important we
must stick to freedom of speech freedom
of speech is the most important thing
but we must stop people generating hate
about our language generating hate about
your [ __ ] noggin the nog language
thomas and your tank engine though the
isle of man isn't it he actually
reported to the police and said can we
investigate this to see if this is a
race hate crime suggesting that there
are not many vowels in the Welsh
language and the thing which struck me
was that he was actually the police
commissioner for North Wales oh wow and
he referred it and presumably you know
he should have been investigating for
waste wasting police time I mean just so
the show will be careful within a year
or two the French you're not gonna weigh
with the French we'll be left with
having to pick on tiny minority
countries yeah
kabaah vetted yeah cup of it yeah you
mispronounce the name and there
I quite like the you clarified that it
was one specific watchman because
initially you said they called and I
just had this image in my head of like
the whole course that's a point yeah and
of course that's because I've got loads
of letters in from people said from from
people in Carmarthen and Cardiff and
rill say god I'm so sorry when did we
lose our sense of humor you know
[Music]
so no II of course not it's that liberal
elite with their vested interests who
desperately desire a sense of victimhood
and I suppose they are victims because
they're thick of [ __ ] well we've started
off with what we're going to talk about
absolutely so you you say you're an
equal opportunities [ __ ] and when we and
I read your articles in The Times and I
think they were incredibly funny has
there ever been a point where you've
made a joke that actually you look back
when you think I shouldn't have said
that that was too far over the line no
but there's been a an occasion every
week without fail where I look at
something I've written and think Oh in
the current climate I shouldn't have
written that so I wonder if the subs
will take it out or the editor will take
it out and then I think no you've got to
do that if you cannot you cannot be
constrained by this stuff otherwise it
makes me boring and partisan and I try
not to be part is that in my
offensiveness you know it's sprayed
around liberally like Jimmy Savile would
have sprayed around his seed a peasant
image I mean you're right what happens
actually is my wife reads my copy before
I send it in
with a glass of wine and she reads
through it and she's she's for a quiet
life this is Roger you can't say this I
said why can't I it's true you know it's
true and it's funny what they'll cut it
out and if they don't cut it out the
police will get involved and she's
invariably right but you cannot stop
doing that and then it is getting more
and more the case that you self police
it gets less funny it's it's it's more
and more the case every week that goes
by I thought we were at something I
mentioned this on a different program
before now I thought that maybe last
year we were at something called peak
wank now it's still it's getting worse
it's going worse and you think there's
going to be a backlash because I talk a
lot with comedians we both do and when
you look at something like Dave
Chappelle is released to this new
special Appeals referred to himself as
appeal but yeah yeah of course there is
of course there's that and on the other
side of Stuart Lee who you know I can
remember stuart lee ruffling a few
feathers by saying that what's he called
that guy from the driving program that
people usually cars and Clarkson may he
died or his children which is good
comedy which is good comedy and comedy
coming from the left and driven from the
left from the liberal left though I
wouldn't call it a proper left up music
now the [ __ ] public school boy when
it comes down to it brilliant so he is I
think you guys were the forefront of it
I mean she
constantly the other one who has to sign
a five page document when you go on
stage at a university because there are
so many things which now are not
considered to be funny and if I may say
so you may get away with slightly more
than I because you come from a from what
is cool to be I don't self-identify as
being me know because I would definitely
get me a lot further but also but of
course company against music of course
you're Jewish yeah and I did say that
likely either and so know you guys have
more of the front of it than I am I mean
you know in France this question this is
I think what he's getting at in terms of
the backlash like I did a show about
that contract this year at Edinburgh and
it did very very well with the public
and with a lot of ruse I obviously got a
lot you know The Guardian and all these
people slammed it but I got a lot of
that trap Ryan one star
I wish he'd given me a once on what he
did is actually he went to see all the
non work comedian yeah and instead of
giving us a review he did a whole
write-up in which essentially he he
wouldn't actually give any of us a
review he just made a few comments about
it's a man who knows nothing about
commonly does not have a single Margaret
Thatcher being a comedy quitting sorry
gone so but my point is that those of us
me Leo Geoff know about a Andrew Doyle
who you might know yeah creative
autonomy right we all did pretty well
right so when Francis is asking about
the backlash do you sense that maybe the
peak wanker point is coming well no I
mean in a sense the reason I don't is a
backlash ah I think the people are with
us I don't haven't I think these people
who try to stop us and what we say have
power without hegemony their views are
not shared by the majority of people in
the country remotely
but they are shared by the BBC
commissioning team and they are shared
by the channel 4 right yeah and the
people who dictate well as you the word
you use the current climate yes yeah
yeah you know I had the story only
yesterday on the BBC this is Clendon
where the commitment this is Radio 5
Live and it was about some lesbians
having a night out a nice night out I
think it was in Leeds and a vicious hate
crime had been committed which the
police were reluctant to follow up and
really a fact that I've got themselves
where he works up on it you found out
what exactly had happened and some drunk
blown shouted hello is this a fat
homosexual contingent then don't say
it's not a hate crime and I think when
that is broadcast with this sense of
outrage it's a horrible thing to say
it's not horrible it's nasty it's it's
Pig ignorant but it's it's not you know
get in the cattle vans is it you know
when that is broadcast as being
something about which we should be
viscerally outraged I think the public
listen to that and think what I don't
think they are anywhere near where the
BBC is on this issue you know I just
don't think they I think and this is
where it comes into brexit where brexit
comes into the picture which is that
there is such a disconnect between this
liberal elite and the country between
Parliament in the country but also
between the judiciary the BBC the civil
service and what we consider the rest of
the country it's there's just no shared
common view of the world they're at odds
with each other I think they'd go along
to your gigs enough I think know that
they laugh at the stuff I write apart
from the man yesterday in Canterbury
I enjoyed reading a Facebook update
about that the Frances absolutely
sometimes did you just tell everybody
what happened along I go to London
sometimes and read as infrequently as
possible and people come up and say I
really love your stuff thank you please
keep writing it and there'll be bloody
four out of five
but one person always walk by and go
[ __ ] and that's fine yesterday it states
that I was buying a ticket and a
youngish bloke walked by and he just
turned to me when racist in that own
vine way that they have and but it's so
intent was in delivering this
gentleman's that he failed to notice a
large door and smashed into it smashed
his face into it and smashed his arm on
the handle and I just stood there if it
had been appropriate I would have
masturbated the instant camera moments
they are enjoyable in London one was
when I was getting on there were two but
Stratford it was quite crowded tube was
about to go doors for about to shut and
there was this black lady with two
carrier bags and she couldn't and the
doors were better stuff I held the doors
open for her took one of the bags and
helped her run as a train I said I would
have expected you to do that bizarre and
there was one other I was walking with I
was having lunch with in the air
bungalow wallah
who was at the time the number two or
three in the Muslim Council of Britain
we were having a lunch to talk about you
know Islam and Stefan and I've known him
for years and we were crossing busy road
I think I think was Hoban area because
it's a very busy road and a woman ran
through the traffic tucked on in the
sleeve and said so there is this
minority which which you know hangs on
its every word you know the Owen Jones
that people be the IQ of Aryan but I
think the vast majority of the public
just thinks this is an annoying
diversion from what we should be talking
about you know at the last election
polling has been done in the States
political correctness was a really
really big reason why Donald Trump won
congratulations USA and you know so when
you talk about a backlash I think people
are averse to it identify whether it's a
backer I think they've always been
diverse to it they're sick of it how
that expresses itself in the end
politically is a more difficult thing to
talk about but to my mind if you've got
this whole raft of people who are the
people who go to university with the
people who go to Oxford and Cambridge
and you're never gonna get rid of them
you're very difficult how are you gonna
do it we're talking about grants key in
the master the institution yes we're
talking a bit about Herbert Mac Hooser
it is very very difficult I can tell you
how we do in Russia occasions where
Russia has a point
hmm not many but the BBC for example is
it's a good example the BBC has done a
brilliant job in the last 20 years
of becoming more diverse ethnically when
I joined the BBC you would broke up soon
as you go through seven floors of
exclusively white people till you go to
the canteen on the 8th floor whether it
was all black yeah that's changed and
it's good that it's changed it's good
try some sort of legislation to ensure
that this diversity of opinion should it
not be necessary for our big news and
current affairs programs to have a kind
of broad sweep of opinion on there
particularly given that we all pay for
them given the real pay for them you
know so they should be encouraged to
have diversity of opinion rather than
this monolithic culture which he has at
the moment Islands I don't see that's a
problem now what do you do about
universities could you do the same thing
I think you probably can and the
universities think universities have
always tended to the left generally but
as we know from the statistics they've
become more and more left-wing it's now
so in the region 95 percent I think that
in the u.s. it's Democrat a few things
have fed into that one of them is the
fact that so many people go to
university now to do utterly [ __ ]
fatuous degrees almost always in social
sciences yeah that's been the big growth
area wank which will cost these poor
kids 40,000 quid you know to come away
from the Queen Mary University or the
University of Westminster University of
Westminster with a degree in gender wank
I mean it would be more interesting to
deal with the teachers as well because
it's another area where again there is
heading towards close to unanimity of
opinion and I spoke to a lad who
the book inverted leave and he was a
teacher of the school in London and the
hatred he got from colleagues just
incomprehensible hatred you know how did
how the [ __ ] do you attack that how do
you stop that there was a headmaster of
a school in Dulwich who said that if any
people in this school said anything
similar to what Donald Trump had been
saying about immigration they would be
expelled
I mean this is mad you know and I don't
know what you do about that I mean close
down the [ __ ] teacher training
colleges you know just what the [ __ ] do
they learn there you know and I think
the growth of some of the free schools
it's an antidote to that Kathryn Birbal
seeing on the show the Catholic bubbles
sing should be our educational policy
should be dictated by Catherine bubbles
sin and Tony Sewell mmm yeah Tony is
Tony's a great mate and a lovely bloke
and he would make a brilliant education
etc so with Catherine that's what you
need yeah and just get rid of this
flaccid self-serving and contradictory
toss that the kids are taught at the
moment because this is a great thing
about and it's why liberalism's falling
apart that these identity politics and
policy of politics stuff is it's all new
Chile contradictory and it falls apart
you tuck under one little thread of it
and it falls apart like a mo hedge um
permitted by the village idiot which we
saw with the protests in Birmingham
about sex education in school yes and
it's interesting because former teacher
I was a teacher for a living you know
sorry but one thing I found very
interesting is how identity politics has
actually started to infect teacher
training so for instance we went to
course um one of them was about how to
teach black boys why that and then you
had to treat them differently no and so
this is where totally sold would change
the world
and the thing is I'm sitting there going
well this is just basically racism
because you're looking at somebody and
you're not actually thinking you know
what their capabilities are how I could
do it they are thinking they're black
you're thinking they're black they're
male therefore we have to treat them
differently two things on that I mean
you're absolutely right it's racist
Tony ones picked up on it a long time
ago so when he first came when I first
notice a guy when there was a kind of
Seacole mania I don't know if you
remember it but it was a time when every
building in Britain had to be named
Seacole house because he was a black
woman who would be an aspirational
figure for black students
Antonio said why should they aspire to
be a [ __ ] nurse what just because
she's got black skin why shouldn't they
aspire to be Faraday or Shakespeare why
do they why why it's it's all of this
stuff is racist it is racist it is it is
it is letting down you know a community
which could have so much more to aspire
to this and corralled into this
perpetual state of victimhood and it
just come on it's crippling it's
critical because what you're saying is
that you will never be capable of doing
all the other children that's right for
because we need to put in special
provisions we have settings also a form
of narcissism because look what I'm a
good person
that's right it's virtuous it well yeah
that's right and but we're also doing it
with boys and we had one training
session where we had a teacher training
person come in tell us how boys can be
expected to write a desk for longer than
15 minutes they needed to have a break
and it's this yeah and then you know
they have to do small targets in order
to keep them engaged it's bollocks
I have to use problems with my
or to sort of grammar school she passed
her eleven plus of course I mean it's
got my genes and identity politics and
the propaganda is now in kinder every
subject apart from maths and physics
it's in geography English it's
everywhere when you study of mice and
men by Steinbeck you are asked what does
this tell us about sexism in nineteen
fifties nineteen thirty's informed us
but you know nothing about the book it's
about it's all corralled into the to
this this monomaniacal hierarchy of
victimhood and it's it's terribly
debilitating but as I say I mean the
good news is it is falling apart you
know believe me the transgender stuff
the fury of the lesbian community and
the feminist community and to an
increasing degree the male gay community
it's all beginning to fall apart at the
edges because of course it has to
because you can't build a world like
that where it's all about computing
victimhood
it's it's an absurdity why do you think
it has been so tremendously successful
do you think it's because we are
naturally wired for empathy and so when
someone claims victimhood we are
naturally drawn to go oh would you feel
bad therefore I should try and take your
concerns into account even if they're
not necessarily based in reality in
certain instances that's it I think that
may be why some people that's a good
explanation of why some well-meaning
middle-class people may feel that but I
think the most of it devolves from the
notion that the capitalism is bad which
it may be that it's run by white males
who are therefore bad that the Cold War
comes into it political alignment comes
into
basically that we are the white
oppressive state and everyone else is de
facto subjugated I mean I remember back
in 1980 83 84 beginning to see this I
think that's what it began late
seventies early eighties when the
National Union of Journalists are
advised by the Commission for racial
equality that henceforth henceforth
Chinese people should be described as
being black I was on the far left at
this point I thought what the [ __ ] and
in various places around London and
Manchester various people but this was
an attendant and it's it's it's the root
of it all to say that the Chinese people
are objectively black because they are
subjects of an oppressive white state
and everybody and it's wide Peter
Tatchell who I respect as a guy normally
and get on with terribly well will
sometimes say to me Muslims and gay
people or to try and make common cause
against the oppression which they've
suffered Society right I wouldn't go up
any tall buildings you know and he was a
guy who stood up for the Irish bakers
the Northern Irish bankers he believes
in freedom of speech he is a good man
but there is his blind spot
you know we are all victims we are all
victims you're affected you see that's
the thing because my mom's from
Venezuela so I do almost yes she [ __ ]
is you can drink now for you as a
trigonometry I mention it every episode
know it she [ __ ] hates him yeah she
loves Trump because Trump is the only
one who's actually doing something yeah
but she despises you know but it's their
thing of what we are all victims we're
all victims yeah and and the other
fascinating thing if you've got time to
talk about yeah it's a bit like with
charities that you begin by saying that
you're a victim that these people in
society of victims and who set up
charities who set up legislation
charities begin to work for legislation
legislation is enacted to protect those
people but it becomes an industry and
what always happens is that it expands
so that for example with disability at
one point there is absolutely no
question that disabled people in this
country had a really really bad run of
it probably still do in many cases and
it's the same stuff as well it's no
longer enough to say that this is a
persecuted minorities any you have to
say if it's not a minority did you know
that one in three people are disabled
well no they're not but that's what the
disabled the disability law we will tell
you yeah and there are now invisible
disabilities and people who are
depressed will get free parking did you
know that no oh yes free parking for
people who are depressed we're all
[ __ ] depressed
are we not but but it's the same as the
gay lobby as well which is undoubted
horrible discrimination but it's not
enough it's we don't just want to that
is it's one in three people are gay or
one in four people
no they're not you know you don't have
to do that but that's what we've done
with all of this stuff it expands
exponentially until we are all victims
we could all be disabled if we want to
be i could register is disabled now you
know my eyesight's not brilliant and
from Middlesbrough we could all register
now and that's what we've done we're
trying to make everyone victims it's
bizarre it is bizarre and two because I
was going to move on I was just gonna
say I'm curious still to prod you more
on why you think that idea of victim had
has been so successful because that is a
a huge transformation because we like
being victims but but here's the thing
right is 40 or 50 years ago we had an
aspirational culture you what you were
taught to be strong particularly if you
were a man you were taught to be strong
you were taught to be resilient you were
taught your job as a human being is to
face the challenges that life throws at
you the movies that we would watch so
the Sylvester Stallone in Rocky saying
life hits harder than anything you ever
imagined but it's by keeping calmed by a
culture we were being combed back then
by a by a paternalistic patriarchal but
I think there's also something appealing
in that we are all victims I think
everybody likes it his power its power
this parent it and also cachet yeah you
know my daughter's school you know as
soon as you start talking about
transgender is more pansexuality or gray
sexuality and all the other sexualities
here they're all certainly enough for
them you know I'm different I'm like
that whereas I at school what I was
trying to be different with strip naked
and stand like Jesus Christ in front of
people and scream that then
you sent a help which I thought actually
took a bit of doing
yeah you know just identifying suddenly
your career makes a lot of sense is also
an easy get out and say I'm not
responsible for my that's right it's a
condition syndrome as well yeah
everything is a condition ADHD and I
mean the two obvious ones are a PhD in
dyslexia yeah you know it's very very
difficult to tell the difference between
scientifically between someone who's
dyslexic and someone middle-class mum
and dad you know ADHD now you're a
little [ __ ]
you were wondering why there's so much
swearing in this episode we unlike with
other guests we get a cup of tea or a
glass of wine
he was honest and decent on brexit for a
while against his better interests he
was principled he's thick of [ __ ] I mean
we know this to Easi a lot more Jesus
yeah sure but also I mean there's there
is no imagination or I don't think he's
read properly I don't think he reads
things and you know it's an intelligence
his existence in the labour party was an
indulgence much as I was indulgent in
1976 when I joined the Socialist Workers
Party I knew at 16 that we weren't going
to hand out weapons at I CI and take
over the country you know it was a bit
of fun all that lot are stuck in that
pre-adolescent mindset it is it is
astonishing
Simon Evans has this great joke in his
new show where he talks about how he
talks about all the different
politicians and make fun of both sides
and then he goes with Jeremy Corbyn of
course he started in student politics
where he remains to this day and it's
it's the [ __ ] affluent who fall for
it that being said I know quite a lot of
people in London and try to work this
out psychologically who vote for Jeremy
Corbyn and then pray he doesn't get in
you know that that is kind of the lefty
virtue signaling writ large as well on
that happy now rod we've got just one
more question for you yeah which is what
is the one thing that no one's talking
about that we ought to be talking about
animal rights yeah I'm sorry I'm I'm so
so I'm really really dull on animal
rights they're gonna have to cut this I
think animal rights is one of the
biggest foods which I there's two things
there's rights for working-class people
who I don't class in the same group as
animal
[Music]
so two things I think we need identity
politics for the working class Niall
says that we need to I think we need to
clamp down on the abuse of animals
raised for food and if anyone ever
suggest bringing back a fox hunting bill
they should actually be shot through the
head with a kind of bulb gun or a rail
gun if you seen any rail guns which oh
so those two things those are so you
think we need identity politics for the
working class rather than just moving
away from identity politics in general I
always be the bit flippant okay by and
large that's the one identity which is
never I know it isn't it isn't but my
point is I think we need to remove
identity politics as a fling sure Roger
that cause I do yeah of course you do
you do yeah I just think one concern for
me with identity politics is it pushes
people who are not represented by it
into their own identity and then you
suddenly get you know 10 million
straight white men going oh yeah well we
are discriminated against because we're
straight white men that's not gonna end
very well no but that'll happen what
that's my point that will happen which
is why no I don't think when you don't
sure sure I mean it's actually a quote
from Morris when a Morris classmen he
says you know the Labour Party has all
this identity politics but none of it
about the people it was set up to
represent yeah and that that's roughly
where I'm from which is why you should
vote the Social Democrats so much for
coming check out columns as you can see
is an edgy and very funny man with some
very good ideas as always follow us
because you're not on social media I
know this for a fact right yeah Polly
was a fraud on Facebook he's pretty
active on there on Twitter yeah yeah
yeah you'd get canceled very quickly
which would be great for your career
okay do you know what being canceled it
kicked off because oh no no being
canceled is like where people start
calling for you to be removed from your
newspaper not being allowed to write
anymore
I do that already yeah but on Twitter
that that would be a lot better so you
should definitely get on it okay thank
you yeah so when rod gets on Twitter
follow him on Twitter as always follow
us at trigger pod and all the social
media we're going to be a quick outro
and we will see you in a week from now
absolutely see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word